créée il ya seulement quelques semaines
le réseau ami a mené sa première
opération devant la préfecture des
yvelines
la cinquantaine de personnes présentes a
réclamé un meilleur accueil des migrants
elle a exprimé aussi ses inquiétudes
quant à la politique menée par le
gouvernement sur la question migratoire
la france pays terre d'accueil cinquième
puissance du monde peut accueillir
dignement des migrants pas quelques
milliers mais bien 150 ou 200 mille
personnes sur 66 millions ça pose
absolument aucun problème
d'autant plus que ces gens ces jeunes
ses fans les enfants nous apporte la
richesse de leur culture de
reconnaissance constitué de différentes
organisations associations et collectifs
le nouveau réseau à me soutient les
migrants dans leurs démarches juridiques
apporte aussi une aide matérielle
culturelles et sportives l'an passé cent
mille personnes ont demandé l'asile en
france pour faire passer leurs messages
plusieurs membres du réseau ont
rencontré directement le préfet des
yvelines ce qu'elle attend surtout c'est
que cette loi que le préfet ne savent
pas les écouteurs de des doigts de la
pas encore évalué la halle à
l'efficacité de la loi qui est actuel et
on est en train d'en faire d'en faire
une autre qui est encore pire que celle
là encore le projet de loi asile et
immigration sera débattue courant avril
à l'assemblée nationale pour tenter de
convaincre les députés de la république
en marche yvelinois de voter contre les
membres du réseau ont envoyé une lettre
ouverte aux parlementaires